الينا من عمان البحث والكاتب في العلاقات
الدوليه دكتور حميد الكفايه اهلا وسهلا بك
موسكو تسعى الحصول على قذائف مدفعيه
وصواريخ مضاده للدبابات من كوريا الشماليه
ما الذي تستفيده ربما كوريا الشماليه من
هكذا تقارب مع موسكو
وكانت قد زودتها بالاسلحه سابقا ولكنها لا
تستطيع لم تستطع على الاقل ان تستمر في
تزويدها بالاسلحه لانها تريد الاسلحه
لنفسها ايضا هي دوله مهدده
وهذا هو
الذي تريده وانه هي تريد ان تساعد روسيا
في حربها واوكرانيا وكذلك تستفيد ماديا لا
تنسى ان كوريا الشماليه ايضا دوله محدوده
الامكانيات وهي بحاجه الى الاموال التي
تولدها الاسلحه مبيعات الاسلحه الى روسيا
وهذه فرصه بالنسبه لها ولكن في العام
الماضي توقفت عن ارسال الاسلحه الى روسيا
بسبب
نفاذ الاسلحه لم تعد هناك اسلحه يمكن
تتخلى عنها كوريا الشماليه ولكن هناك
مشكله تواجهها فعلا هي قدمت الاسلحه
لروسيا لروسيا لان هناك عقوبات قد تفرض
عليها اكثر من العقوبات الحاليه قد تدخل
نفسها في مشاكل مع الولايات المتحده ومع
الدول الغربيه
ولكن نحن نعلم
كوريا الشماليه لا تكت
للمجتمع الدولي ولا يهمها
متوقع عنها قد تتعاون مع روسيا في هذا
المجال
ولكن
تبقى اعتقد ان العمليه سوف تبقى سريه
ولا يعلن عنها مثل ما حصل بالساده طيب
يعني شحنه الذخيره المحتمره من كوريا
الجنوبيه لاوكرانيا بطبيعه حال تشكل مصدر
قلق ربما لموسكو هل يمكن القول بان هذه
الزياره هي نوع من ربما الابتزاز
الدبلوماسي من قبل روسيا هل هي خطوه تحذر
فيها بانه اذا تمت تم تزويد اوكرانيا من
قبل كوريا الشمال كوريا الجنوبيه عفوا
ربما موسكوسه تفعل المثل
هو هذه الزياره هي في الحقيقه لحضور
المؤتمر الاقتصادي الشرقي الذي اسسته
روسيا في عام 2015
وهذا المنتدى يضم روسيا
وكوريا الشماليه وافغانستان وايران
بالاضافه الى الهند
وهذا يعقد اعماله في في تزامن مع قمه
عشرين
المنعقده في الهند
الرئيس الروسي لم يستطع ان يحفظ قيمه
العشرين لاسباب كثيره منها المذكره
الاعتقال الصادره بحقه
لذلك هذه زياره كانت متوقعه ان يزور
الرئيس الكوري الشمالي روسيا
توطيد العلاقات بالتاكيد وكذلك بحجه او
لحضور هذا المنتدى
الاقتصادي الثقافي
الذي اسسته روسيا لتطوير علاقات مع الدول
الاخرى
التي تقيم معها علاقاتها القوه الاخرى
المتحالفه معها
سوف تزود اوكرانيا بالاسلحه ولكن بالتاكيد
كوريا الشماليه فعل ذلك في الماضي مع
روسيا شكرا لك يا دكتور حميد الكفاء
الباحث والكاتب في العقد دوليه كنت معنا
من عمان